[Music]
the second half of ursula kayla green's
short story on the high marsh found in
her tales from earthsea
concerns this character erie athaz did
the first half but now we get to find
out
who and what
he is or rather
was and who he will become and this
happens because we now have a new
character
coming in previously we had iriah who's
rather confused
seems to be very talented and
knowledgeable but also a bit fuzzy
headed we have gift or emmer a gift is
her use name emmer is her true name a
widow who has taken him in and who's
taking care of him as well and now we
get a third important person
coming into the mix and we're told
sunbright the sorcerer the village
sorcerer filled with jealousy who irioth
had almost attacked and then fell down
in a fit uh
in front of had not been gone three
years when a new stranger appeared in
town a man riding up the south road on a
good horse asking at the tavern for
lodging they sent him to sand's house
sand's wife screeched when he heard was
a stranger at the door
and so they sent him up the way to
gifts house send him out on the dairy
said one of alder's cowboys gifts taking
whatever comes and then they the
taverner says all the foreigners in one
basket and this was repeated that night
at the tavern several dozen times an
inexhaustible source of admiration the
best thing anyone had said since the
murder this is the kind of small town
mentality right and as it turns out who
is this stranger
it's gad the archmage
of earthsea
gift is in the dairy
and gad comes saying i'm looking for a
bed for the night
and then he she says well i'm full up
and and he says that's okay i'll sleep
in the cow barn you know it's a good
place for me to be
and he calls himself master hawk
she says i'm gift put your horse up and
see to him there's the pump come in the
house after i can give you a bit of milk
soup and a penny will be more than
enough thank you
and so he's there squatting on the
hearth making up the fire the cure was
in his room asleep she looked in and
closed the door
he's not too well she said speaking low
he was curing the cattle away over
out east over the marsh in the cold for
days on end and he wore himself
out and they talk a little bit about
that
and she also talks about the other
sorcerer uh who wasn't any good uh you
know
he did no good to my car with a cake bag
two years ago his balms just pig fat i'd
swear
and then hawk says mistress may i tell
you a story and she says oh are you a
teller why didn't you say so to begin
with is that what you're is that what
you are then i wondered it being winter
and all and you being on the roads but
with a horse i thought you might be a
more merchant can you tell me a story it
would be the joy of my life and the
longer the better but drink your soup
first and let me sit down to hear and he
says i'm not truly a teller mistress and
a little bit later he's going to say now
this is not a story for you to spread
around but i'm going to tell you a story
and it quickly becomes apparent who this
story is about
first he tells her about rogue
in the inmost sea on the isle of the
wise on rogue island where all major he
is taught there are nine masters
he named the master's hand and herbal
summoner and patterner winkey enchanter
the namer and the changer the changers
and the summoners are very perilous arts
he said changing your transformation you
maybe know of mistress even a common
sorcerer may know how to work illusion
changes have you seen that
and then he talks about
bringing
the dead back and that is summoning
naming truly a great power to know the
true name is to have power as you know
mistress and the summoner's art goes
straight to that it's a wonderful thing
to summon up the semblance and spirit of
one long dead and then he says well to
my story
40 years and more ago there was a child
born on the isle of arc this child was
the son of an understeward the parents
died young not much heed was paid to
them until they began to take notice of
him because of what he did and could do
he was uncanny brat as they said he had
powers he could light a fire or douse it
with a word he could make pots and pans
fly through the air and what they do
instead of
taking care of him is they bind him they
try to prevent him from using his powers
nobody teaches him
he was only a child and the wizards of
that household can't have been wise men
for they used little wisdom or
gentleness with him maybe they were
afraid of him they bound his hands and
gagged his mouth to keep him from making
spells they locked him in a cellar room
in a room full of stones a room of stone
till they thought him tamed they sent
him away to live at the stables of the
great farm for he had a hand with the
animals and was quieter when he was with
the horses but he quarreled with a
stable boy and turned the poor lad into
a lump of dung when the wizards had got
the stable boy back into his own shape
they tied him up again gagged his mouth
and put him on a ship for rope they
thought mass maybe the masters there
could tame him so they are already
adopting the wrong
way to deal with this unruly child they
send him to rock and at rock
the masters do their best
they didn't punish him but they kept his
wild powers bound with spells until they
could make him listen and begin to learn
why
there was a rival of his spirit in him
that made him look on any power he did
not have anything he did not know as a
threat
a challenge a thing to fight against
until he could defeat it there are many
boys like that i was one but i was lucky
i learned my lesson
young there are many people like that in
the world are there not who see any
challenge
any opposition as a threat that then has
to be mastered has to be dominated has
to be crushed has to be put down and so
even
trying to keep that within limits is
difficult because as you're guiding
somebody like that they can see your
guidance let alone your binding as a way
of trying to control them they view the
world in a very
you know
what would we say a very zero-sum sort
of way somebody has to be in charge it
may as well be
me
and so
they do manage to get him to start
paying attention and to learning and
he's a very strong
learner and he decides that he's going
to go to the art that is one of the
greatest of all that of summoning
and here is where things start to really
go
awry
what is forbidden to the summoner or any
wizard is to call a living spirit we can
call to them we can send to them a voice
or present them and a seeming of ourself
but we don't summon them in spirit or
flesh to come to us only the dead may we
summon only the shadows to summon a
living man is to have entire power over
him body or mind so it can be done
but here's the next line that's very
important no one no matter how strong or
wise or great
can rightly own
and use another now that doesn't mean
that one can't own and use another the
rightly is the key thing there it will
always be damaging it will always be
wrong it will always generate evil in
doing this
this young man
decides that
there was no place for him among the
masters since a new master summoner had
been chosen
among the scholars and other teachers he
had a place of honor but he wasn't one
of the nine he'd been passed over maybe
it wasn't a good thing for him to stay
there always among wizards and mages
so he began to practice certain arts
that are not well to practice and lead
to no good things
a summoner grows used to bidding spirits
and shadows to come to his will and go
at his word
maybe this man began to think who's to
forbid me from doing the same with the
living why have i the power if i cannot
use it so he began to call the living to
him those that wrote who he feared
thinking them rivals those whose power
he was jealous of when he came to them
he took their power from them for
himself leaving them silent they
couldn't say what had happened to them
what had become of their power they
didn't know
and then eventually
he decides to take a a drastic step he
summons his own master the summoner of
roke taking him unawares but the
summoner fought him both in body and
spirit and called to me and i came
together we fought against the will that
would destroy us so it's the
really two of the most powerful
mages in earthsea now in tandem against
this other young mage who is also quite
powerful the summoner and the archmage
they
beat him off they drive him off and he
flees
from the isle of roke and he's damaged
in the process he was half mad as ged
says now he became fully mad and then
ged thought to himself
it's probably not a good thing to have a
man of very great power a mage wandering
about earth sea not in his right mind
maybe full of shame and rage and
vengefulness we'd better track this guy
down we'd better figure out what became
of him
and this is where we find out
this is the man
irioth was that person the guy sleeping
having healed all those cattle in the
other room in gifts cottage
is this great mage and
the person sitting in front of her is
the archmage
of earthy
and
irioth comes out
he saw he he calls him
there
she looked at the door of the bedroom
and opened and he stood there thin and
tired his dark eyes full of sweep sleep
and bewilderment and pain
ged he bowed his head
will you take my name from me so iriath
is making a request of ged he knows that
he should be punished in some way
something should be done to him he's
gained a certain kind of wisdom and ged
says why should i do that
he says my name means only hurt
hate pride greed
god says i'll take those names from you
erioth but not your own and then iriath
says something very important that shows
that he's learned something all too late
along the way
i didn't understand about the others
that they are other we are all other we
must be
i was wrong now that sounds rather
confusing but what is he actually saying
there
he wasn't able to recognize the
you might say the legitimate reality the
dignity
of other people
that they really do
matter that they're not just there to
oppress him
and bind him and as a force to be fought
against and to master in his own right
rather they are something to be dealt
with
in other ways that we're all like that
he now understands
this and this is a very
important lesson
ged says you went wrong you've come back
but you're tired eric and the way is
hard when you go alone and now ged
suggests to him
come home with me come back to rock
we'll let you back in we're not going to
take vengeance upon you
we'll try to undo
whatever damage has still you know
lasted up to this time but we're not
going to
hurt you and irioth says
i have worked here
gad looked at at her at gift he does she
said he heals the cattle
iriath says they show me what i should
do and who i am they know my name but
they never say it
and then we see god being tender with
iriath after a while ged gently drew the
older man to him and held him in his
arms he said something quietly to him
and let him go
irith drew a great breath i'm no good
there it rock you see god i am here if
they'll let me do the work he's found a
place for himself to exercise his
talents
he looked again at gift and gad did also
she looked at them both and this is very
important
all three characters are coming to
an understanding
about the
life going forward and it's not just a
life for iria
because gift or emmer
she's somebody who has
also been looking for something
who needs something in her own life the
life that is going to be lived now is
not just one
for a solitary mage area it's one
with emmer
he ged says what say you emmer i'd say
she said her voice thin and reedy
speaking to the cure that if all those
beaves stay afoot through the winter the
cattlemen will be begging you to stay
though they not may not love you nobody
loves the sorcerers of the archmage well
eerie often i come all this way for you
in the dead of winter and must go back
alone and irioth says
tell them i was wrong tell them i did
wrong and ged says i'll tell them that
the changes in a man's life may be
beyond all the arts we know and all our
wisdom
and then ged says may he stay here
mistress is it your wish as well as his
and she says he's ten times the use and
company to me my brother is and a kind
true man as i told you sir
and then
god says goodbye very well then eerie of
my dear companion teacher rival friend
farewell emmer brave woman my honor and
thanks to you may your heart and hearth
know peace and he made a gesture that
left a glimmering track between it a
moment in the air above the hearthstone
now i'm off to the cow barn so get is
giving them
not just a blessing but a magical
blessing as well and they have made a
decision about
how things are going to stand
come to the fire she says to irioth
and she asked was that the archmage
truly the archmage of the world in my
cow barn he should have my bed he won't
said irrioth she knew he was right and
here's how it ends
with a kind of
redemption
at a personal level where it really does
matter
your name is beautiful irioth she said
after a while i never knew my husband's
true name
nor he mine i won't speak yours again
but i like to know it since you know
mine
your name is beautiful emmer he said i
will speak it when you tell me to so
there's an intimacy
between them
that she didn't enjoy even with her own
husband and that is where things are
left for the mage erioth still half mad
still not entirely put together
but now at least
knowing his place and having
said what it is that he did
coming to terms with it
and having been
in a certain way forgiven
by get on behalf of rogue
you